oh my god
okay so last night if you didn't see my
video
before filming that before jimmy fallon
went on air i took like a 40-minute nap
waited for the spider-man 3 title reveal
there was no title reveal on jimmy
fallon did a video about tom hall and
trolling us
and for some reason i just couldn't go
to sleep because i took a little nap
cut to 2 30 in the morning i'm looking
on social media people are like
hey the title is going to come out
around 6 00 a.m probably i was like ah
okay try to get a little bit of sleep
and i got so caught up on waking up
at 6 00 a.m that i didn't fall asleep
till about 4 15 a.m
woke up at six no title reveal i stay
away till
seven i'm dead tired no title reveal
so i've been taking 30 minute naps ever
since seven o'clock
for a damned auto reveal and it's
finally here
let's watch this video that was sent to
us
it's called no way home it's ruined
right here for me
let's do this
[Music]
oh how cool
wow this christmas they're sticking to
their guns on this one hey guys
so yeah this is actually a re-upload
because the video was demonetized this
morning
i was like okay i'll bite the bullet on
that but then when i got out of the
shower
hence this shirt on my head found out
that the video was blocked in some
countries due to the music i had one of
two options cut out the best part of the
reaction
or i mute the best part of the reaction
so i was like well i guess i'll just
re-upload this so that way everyone can
at least watch it uh for those who
didn't get a chance to see it earlier
and also you know since uh it's
re-uploaded i figured i'd add on some
thoughts too to this one
people way more well-versed than me
are gonna be able to break down little
clues home sweet home
gross homeworld's boring can't find home
what close to home it's too close though
this is a funny ass whiteboard stay at
home
stop hard pass zoning home
please stop yeah that part is actually
zooming home and i said
zoning home homeschooled aunt may says
no
homesick home alone
copyright issues welcome home crossout
home run
what it's funny because a lot of these
were a lot of these were working titles
that i was hearing about
want to go home or already there no
place like home trademark uh far from
home we already did this calm home
webcaming keep it pg
needs home i'm just so excited it's here
ah there's so much in here i love like
the little drawings that you have here
too this is a funny ass whiteboard
because a lot of these titles i did here
were some of the working titles another
thing that's been pointed out to me a
lot is how this photo
has a lot of hexagons that in the midst
of all the excitement and rushing i
didn't notice the hexagons before but if
anything this is actually more of an
indicator of how much the events
of wanda vision just might perhaps tie
into the events
of not only doctor strange multiverse
madness but even spider-man
no way home as well as far as the title
for
no way home goes that's a good title i
thought that we were gonna get some
title that was perhaps linking more to
the multiverse you know the fact that dr
strange is gonna be in here and that
we're hearing about
willem dafoe sandman doc gawk being here
and of course the rumors even though tom
holland keeps shutting them down
we a lot of us already believe that's
going to happen that toby mcguire and
andrew garfield are going to be in this
movie as well so i thought we'd be
getting a title that's a little bit more
hinting towards something that's along
like spider-verse or multiverse
to say the least so that's why i was
kind of going with home worlds but as it
stands no way home
does imply that fugitive type of title
and still
can link to the fact that he might be
caught up in some type of
weird multi-dimensional hopping
thingamajig and needs to get back to his
own earth but really if they want to
even hide some of
that if they want to hide a little bit
more of the multiverse thing for now and
they're going with this title
it does work in tune with him being on
the run
it does so i mean they have spider-man
home run here is a title that did not go
with
uh but that does work with him being a
fugitive and uh
having to clear his name i love it i
think it's a good title
you know it's not a mind-blowing title
and one thing
also that i didn't take proper notice of
until i was editing it for the first
upload
the glitch here that you see with the
title some people think that this
is more in reference to the events of
monovision especially because of the
fact
that you have like those hexagons on
there and hearing about how the events
of wanna vision will tie into spider-man
but also it kind of does make you think
of into the spider-verse as well
and if we do not believe tom holland
about tahoe b mcguire that's his name
totally mcguire and andrew garfield
then you know this could be a nod to
that maybe it's not to both or maybe
just a cool effect for this tease
and i do like in terms of the spider-man
trilogy with it being homecoming
and so you know spider-man coming home
to the mcu also dealing with you know
the homecoming dance event and then
far from home then now no
way home i think that's a really cool uh
trilogy type of subtitles to roll with
it's also kind of funny looking at this
promo with tom hollands and dia and
jacob because
i'm like wait a minute all this stuff in
the office decoration looks
like halloween doesn't look like things
from like you
you expect something from maybe
christmas so they just shot this so i
feel like they wanted to announce this
title
a while ago considering the fact that
this
promo looks like it was shot forever ago
i've been very loud in this video i'm
just really trying to stay away i love
the joke about how because he did reveal
the title far from home that was also
something very intentional
it seems like ever since tom holland
became known for spoiling stuff they've
even used that with
the marvel marketing to even play into
that to a certain extent
and i do like the social media photos
that they put out when they put out
those fake titles yesterday i was
watching my buddy chris 3c
film saw his little video yesterday and
he was saying how he thinks that's
actually
the sanctum centorum from doctor strange
and
yeah when you see that image and you
break it down it does actually look like
it's from when they actually all meet dr
strange so
i actually like the idea peter is not
completely on his
own by the time he goes to meet doctor
strange and maybe starts multiverse
hopping that
he actually has his two loyal people by
his side even though there's a rumor
that him and zendaya might break up at
one point in this movie
i do like how he's a fugitive on the run
there's no way for him to just go home
but he's got his two loyal buddies by
him regardless because that's such a big
heart of this franchise as it is and
another part where the photos has been
pointed out to me is some people
actually think this might not be the
sanctum some torum which
to my eyes i actually do think it's more
likely that some people
actually think that this might just
perhaps
be agatha harkness's basement that's
i saw some comments in the previous
video that we're saying that which i
think is a very interesting theory i
don't think that's
likely but i saw a few comments that
people pointed that out
maybe but i i highly doubt that's the
case
anyway guys i'm just so glad this
trailer's here thank you so much
for being here i'm so happy it exists
my spectrum internet has been sucking
the fattest balls in the world lately
even though i'm covering this as soon as
it dropped
i'm probably getting it up later than
everyone else so thank you for being
here hope you enjoyed the video i'll
talk with you guys soon